[Music]
hello everyone Perry here with another
Toronto 2019 interview very excited
about this one we have Andrea Hovig and
stellan skarsgård here to talk about the
movie hope and I was telling you guys a
little bit about this before we even
started I just like I'm blown away by
how you jump just like feet-first into a
project and are completely immersed in a
situation like this which is very
troubling and challenging but for anyone
out there who is experiencing something
like this sometimes it's easier to
process by seeing something represented
on the screen so thank you for making a
movie like this thank you for saying
that what happens when a script like
this crosses your path you immediately
know you have to do it or is there any
hesitation with like I don't know if I
want to be in that brain space for an
extended period of time should I speak
first you should because the director
she has experienced this herself and
that is kind of a red flag because I was
a bit afraid that that she could always
let me know that well this is how it
happened so I could never say yet let's
do this instead but it was never like
that
I felt so free doing this character Anja
and I'm not doing her so I felt very
free from all that really so it was good
could I trouble you to give a brief
synopsis of the movie because a lot of
our viewers out there probably will not
know what hope is about so it would be a
good time to do that okay
it's about Anja who she has three kids
of her own she has a husband well
they're not married yet and they and she
has three stepkids and just before no
three kids alone yes
IIIi think I said that yes I'm very glad
to have Stellan here mm-hmm thank God
and and right before Christmas she gets
this message that she has three months
left to live because she has this tumor
so it's about this Christmas and what
happens with love when you know you're
gonna die oh yeah
but she made this movie so she's
obviously still around yes brilliant
what kind of conversations did you have
with her before jumping in where after
you read the script and you're getting
ready to shoot the movie are there any
burning questions about the situation or
the characters that you needed her to
answer before you were fully ready for
it I had so many questions
so I don't know where to start what
about you Stalin no you should because
it's actually about your own yes well I
wanted to know as much as possible about
her story about and I asked and I talked
to a lot of doctors and nurses about the
physical symptoms that comes along with
medications that she's on I wanted to
know as much as possible because then I
feel so much more free in the process so
I asked her tons of questions and she
was more than willing to share which was
very beautiful and what was it like with
you two getting together for the very
first time to make this movie do you
have a period where you're able to
rehearse or is this the kind of
situation where it's almost like running
gun make sure you get all the scenes
done what it was is it's is great
because we got two weeks of read through
the script and discuss every scene and
understand what what the point with the
scene was where it's going and make sure
that all all our questions got answered
and everything we we was we were afraid
of got a sort of very well handled I
remember I can just tell you a little
story
first time I met Stalin was at a lunch
and I had never met him before we costed
together in this film and after that
lunch I haven't told you this but I was
so relieved that I I went home crying
because I felt with this man I can do
anything and that was such a relief
because you never know and people tell
me well he's such he's so wonderful to
work with but if you hear that too many
times you can actually become a monster
so I was so I was a bit afraid that
everybody knows that he's so brilliant
to work with but but he is and I I now
noticed that at once because we had a
hard love the first time we met which is
very important to me
so what is the top thing that you both
look for in a scene partner something
where the person acting opposite you
needs to give you in order for you to
deliver your best possible work I love a
sense of humor that's important but it's
also important that the actor you work
with is is of the kind that that is not
mainly interested in showing his or her
own brilliance and and and trying to
make a soul out of it because to me
what's interesting with acting and where
my passion is is what happens between
the characters and that means that you
have to be really open and generous and
tolerant and whatever happens you have
to respond to that and that's where
they're often the best things you do in
a film it's not the things that you plan
to do
it's what the what the other actor makes
you do is there any example of a scene
on this movie where that kind of you
know something didn't go to plan or you
were kind of maybe improvising a little
and happy magic came out of it something
you didn't expect we had so many takes
on every scene um we did everything a
thousand times so and it felt new every
time just because of what Stellan just
said that we try to be open and suddenly
he looked at me in a different way which
made me act differently so it it was
like that all the time but well we had
some technical issues in Sweden just
once
so things that didn't go as planned I
don't know I don't know I don't have any
I don't know
I never remember those stories that are
really good for press well that day this
happened one question we've been asking
a lot while we're here and I'm just
curious if something comes to mind
quickly of all of the films you've ever
made is there any one particular scene
you shot that you say I'm never gonna
forget that day no I made a [ __ ]
hundred films
I never thought I'd hit the point where
I'd forget all the things we do on this
circuit or can't recall it you know on
the spot in a heartbeat but when you're
good you forget it but it's I'm I I
don't look back very much I mean I'm
really I love the present and I'm
curious about the future and that's
where I am and I mean I don't even
remember like my kids names you know he
does where's that curiosity leading you
to now like is there any kind of new
curiosity in your career that makes you
choose a movie like this and maybe
whatever is coming after it well this
movie is special because the director is
an old friend of mine and her husband
I've made five films with his a film
director as well so so I I was sort of a
part of this story when it happened for
real and then she wrote a draft synopsis
about the failure she wanted to make and
it was it has such a partly comical and
funny and an artistic touch to it and I
thought that this this will not be like
any cancer cancer film around this would
be something else it would be much more
personal but not indulgent and and and I
just looked and I've admired her as a
director before so it was an easy thing
to get into but what do you really want
to do is the films that haven't been
made and about 90% of the scripts you
read or films that imitates other films
and that's really boring I don't want to
ask for like like what is the meaning or
what is the lesson behind this film but
it is important I think to tell certain
stories like this for someone out there
who might need it so I what what are you
hoping that someone hoping that someone
takes from this film and that actually
reminds me of a follow-up question I
have - I think it's very much about life
not death it's about wanting to live and
wanting to love so it's it's such a
cliche but it's really about love I
think but it's I feel so stupid when I
say that but it's
it's more about wanting to live than
death itself which is really empowering
actually because most of us actually
really want to live for more stupid or
not stupid reasons we most of us want to
live it's me I was gonna ask what you
make of the title of the movie - it was
was that always the title when you say
yes yes it kind of ties into beautifully
- how you just explained the end of the
movie is just the importance of hope and
how it ties to the well to live well I
actually said this is the bad title and
probably if you go if you search on hope
he will probably ten other films called
hopes could you come up with something
better and she really tried and and I
gave her some suggestions that they just
laughed so she said we stuck with hope
do you remember any of those suggestions
no it probably that you would have to
bleep them I feel like the only answer
to the title question is finding like
like a title a really long title that
begins with an A or or a number it puts
it at the tippy top of any less you I
think about that way too often
especially with how prevalent you know
streaming services that alphabetized her
movies are right now for no reason
whatsoever except to make it someone's
top priority when they're scrolling
through a menu I really wanted to ask
you guys about working with the whole
ensemble here because there's a bunch of
like very key scenes where the whole
family is present so what is it like
being directed in a scene like that do
you have very specific marks you need to
hit in those moments or is it more just
the fluidity of family life fluidity of
family life and all the doctors and the
film are actual doctors and nurses which
which kept us on our toes because
they're not colleagues of us there are
actual doctors which which made
everything new all the time and and gave
the film an all tensed a which I really
really enjoyed Stella know you're also
here with another movie the painted bird
and I do not want to forget about that
so just so everybody out there is a
where can you tell them a little bit
about that movie and why it's so
important to you
well that's it's based on a book by
Darcy kasinski the painted bird which is
a very dark but fantastic story about a
young boy in in Europe during the Second
World War who's it's a road movie he
walks around and tries to survive in the
countryside and everybody he meets all
the actors that are in it aren't there
for like me for two days so it's it's a
journey but the director actually
approached me ten years ago and he said
I finally got the rights to Jesse
consider his book do you want to be in
it he said to me and it's a film that
it's absolutely impossible to find us so
I immediate yes of course because it's a
film that I wanted to see and I saw it
now for the first time in Venice and
it's incredibly beautiful it's its
darkest brutal but it there's also so
much true life in it that I think I felt
I left the cinema with hope hope for for
life but also hope for cinema because
it's it's very cinematic like the sound
of that I mean that's one of my
favourite things about being at a
festival like this there are so many
movies that studios are releasing that
are high-quality fair that people are
gonna see nationwide and there's so many
hidden gems and that's the purpose of
these interview is to keep spreading the
love for that and I def you I definitely
want to do that for hope and also for
you in particular because like I don't
think I will ever forget this
performance so thanks do you have
anything else coming up or anything else
that like someone can go and look inside
you with another film as well called
disco where I'm yes and is on my list
yeah and I also participate in them
beware of children which opened in
Venice last week so I'm having three
films this okay that's I imagine you
have your work there it is sucking the
most out of you and of course we have to
talk a little bit about dune we have a
whole lot of dune fans out there so what
has the experience been on that project
thus far especially with a director like
Denis
I always wanted to work with him but
partly because he's such a wonderful man
but also because he's a brilliant
director and he's he is a filmic it's
it's it's it's fun when you get one of
those big sci-fi movies and it's going
to you know it's going to be directed by
a truth filmmaker it's not going to be
directed by the studio and they it
seemed like they were giving him pretty
free hands and you have to because his
personal stamp on the film is paramount
for the success of it so I had a lot of
fun doing it but I but it was but I had
seven hours in makeup every day because
I had to be really fat so it was hard
walking away from it what do you think
it is about his rendition of dune that's
really gonna you know capture the hearts
and imaginations of a wide audience
because it is not an easy book to adapt
no it isn't but and his is what he's
really good at is creating this strange
atmosphere with his imagery and and this
cinematic poetry that is his trademark
and that will will add so much richness
to to the pretty simple story and just
to wrap this up on a light note to
celebrate life and all the wonderful
things we have I've got a couple of
Collider random questions for you shoot
like really random stuff whatever the
first thing is that comes to your mind
what is the one TV show that you would
want to guest star on none Oh many
guests are on afterlife by Ricky Gervais
fleabag you yes yes so much good
television out there it's fantastic and
it's wonderful the Americans oh to be in
the Americans are there are so many yeah
I could probably go on and on myself yes
you could what is the movie that you
quote the most that you avoid I don't
quote anyone I don't quote either I told
you about my memory how it works I just
forget and go on you know yeah and I get
so embarrassed by this quoting thing I I
never do it I I get too embarrassed as
they say in taxi driver I know I can't
do that well the fact that you just
named dropped taxi driver yes
I never do that my go-to is hold on to
your butts
you know what that comes from Jurassic
Park okay yeah good for you that wasn't
nice what is the background photo on
your cell phones my kids it's actually I
wanted something textured with black so
I just took a photo of my jeans it's not
very yeah sorry it's very practical I
can understand that and for a while I
had a close-up of a brick I mean you
find nice colors and nice textures and
everywhere around I'm Morris I know what
is your onset vice the thing that you
turn to when like I don't you need a
drink or a piece of food what can you
never be seen on set without coffee I
feel yeah coffee it's also I can't be on
a set where people are not enjoying
themselves because it's hard enough as
it is and if you don't have a good
atmosphere on the set if people are not
happy on this side then I really don't
want to be there so I want to see happy
people around me me too that's a quote
by the way
I want to see fat happy people are
that's from Julius Caesar okay there we
go
yeah the movie based on some play all
right I have to say goodbye to you guys
but thank you so much for your time
today please keep an eye out for hope
they're really exceptional in it and the
painted bird as well and like the whole
slew of movies that you've got coming up
set now I can't wait to see even more
please do not leave this interview
without liking and sharing and also a
huge huge thanks to our sponsors over at
Nordstrom Canada these can't happen
without them so we greatly appreciate
them sponsoring these interviews guys
we're gonna see you soon with more
Tiff's 20:19 coverage